this is going to be Monumental for me
because I've never done
an official speed run before
and this is actually one of the
differences one of the small differences
between
leeches and chess.com
you can get an authorized speedrun
account
where it will start at a very low rating
and then I can basically try and climb
the reading ladder
now there's a small thing to explain
with what I'm about to do
so I reached out to chess.com admins got
set up with this account oh no my Rosen
I still need to add a profile picture
if anyone has suggestions let me know if
this goes on YouTube let me know what my
profile picture should be
but
basically I made this account I played a
couple games on it but then what
happened was my rating increased
very quickly I started at 400 I won my
first game
uh maybe I can just show my games really
quickly
I won my first game like this opponent
just allowed me to take on F7
welcome to 400 ELO chess ratings are not
even displayed here
uh game ended in checkmates
and then the next game was even shorter
that first game was nine moves the next
game I played was seven moves it came
from a copycat Petrov where yeah my
opponent took the pawn fell for this
very common opening trap
the pawn defended the knights I kicked
the Knight the Knight moved and then I
played Knight C6 attacking the queen and
the King
and after this this my opponent resigned
and after just two games
I gained
almost 300 points I went from 400 to
690.
so I messaged uh the chess.com people
and they said with these new speed run
accounts
I have to play about 15 games before my
rating becomes less volatile
and after those about 15 games they can
reset my rating back to 400.
so my plan for
the next I don't know hour we'll see how
long it takes
but the plan for now is to play
about 10 to 15 games
and just get a more established rating
and then then I can message them to have
them reset the rating back to 400 that
way it will be less volatile
so if that's confusing sorry but
basically I'll be playing
a bunch of games and trying to win
quickly and punish beginner mistakes
and this should be fun I'm already
getting challenges
but I'm gonna join a 10 minute game
and here is my my first opponent the
maodoi
if two tabs open
and I'm gonna try and make this like as
instructive as possible
but I'm also going to try and show no
mercy like my opponent is clearly a new
player rated 548.
and I'm going to follow basic principles
like I probably won't be doing any like
very deep tricky opening preparation
we're just gonna stick with
basic principles at least in the
the earlier games
this is one of the first openings I
played as a chess player
I started
playing at age seven that's why I
learned the rules
played my first tournament at age eight
and the Italian was
an opening I I loved
um and one of the benefits of the
Italian is you can Castle as early as
move four
that's basically the earliest you can
Castle in a chess game
and the benefit to counseling early is
if the Center opens up
and the pun's king is on the center
then
it can lead to very good things
now in this position I would really like
to achieve D4
but
black has three attackers
and when you're first starting chess
this is actually something to like be
very aware of like if I play D4 I have
two Defenders black has three attackers
so the way to prepare a D4 is C3
and this is basically a delayed panziani
we have ponziani opening would have been
C3 in this position
a little bit delayed but yeah the idea
is to play D4
and because now I have three Defenders
I'm not losing material
and now black is in a kind of
predicament because
yeah The Bishop's attacked and I'm
taking over the center
and this is usually the Dream from early
on like at two
nice Center pawns also winning time
because uh the bishop
has to move again
and I'll develop
it's possible that like moves like D5 or
E5 were were playable
but I'm more focused on trying to
develop the pieces
I will say my points like playing not
bad for rated less than 600. uh Bishop
G4 is a good move
threatening to
either take the Knight and then win the
pawn or just take the pawn right away
because my Knight's pinned
so
I might have to play defensively here
I don't want to play a move like D5
because that allows 95.
although maybe that's what I go for and
then Bishop E2
I mean they'll play a little bit more
provocatively with Bishop
E3
this is what we call over defense
where the pawn was already like
seemingly defended twice but needs to be
defended the third time now that my
Knight's gone and rather than taking
with a queen
which would lose upon I'm going to take
with the pawn
I was not expecting to have like more
high level concepts with this first game
um at first this looks a little bit
ugly or like self-destructive that I've
castled and have double Pawn so my king
is more Exposed on the g-file
but the reason why I don't mind this
especially after black castles is I have
a very simple fact King H1
with Rook G1 to follow
and I can turn what looks to be a
weakness into a very powerful strength
that would be funny if I was playing
like another streamer who's also doing a
speed run I guess the sakaru's alt
account
but probably not
so anyway yeah with King H1 uh The Rook
is gonna find
a very pleasant home
and generally like leading into the
middle game you want to put your Rooks
on
open files which are files with no Pawns
or half open files which is a g file
it's a file with uh just one black pawn
and we see this move H6 this is a common
I think beginner thing where once they
complete the opening
sometimes players just don't know what
to do so they they just move a random
flank pawn and
um the H6 is probably more harmful to
Black than it is helpful because now I'm
threatening to take the pawn
but maybe black will play King H7 and
get off the G file
so I'm not up any material yet
but from a
positional standpoint like things are
very nice I have Center control
even though I have double pawns they're
not really weak
and the pieces are going to coordinate
thanks as always oh thank you all the
great content Singapore backgammon
yeah for anyone just joining this is a
the first game I'm playing on stream on
this new
speedrun account
the readings aren't even displayed
because my the account is so new
um but we can see this is my provisional
rating 690.
opponents taking time here
I'm actually a little bit curious if my
opponent
is a viewer knows I'm streaming
um
or if they just like got paired randomly
and has no idea
I imagine maybe there are some people
who are
trying to join the pool or join the pool
and get a game
so yeah it's a difficult position for
black
honestly I'd probably take time here as
black as well
but sometimes when you're under pressure
like the first thing to ask is what is
the threat
and if it's a strong threat how do I
stop it so black should address that
the g-pawn is pinned
and uh I guess they didn't realize so
now it's time to
indulge
have a nice appetizer
I think it only gets worse from here
because not only is this Pawn pinned but
it's attacked twice
it's not so easy to defend
if the pawn moves it hangs a rook
also there there is a funny idea if the
pawn moves to G6
I don't even have to take the Rook
I could take the pawn
because this Pawn is also pinned by the
bishop so it can't take
it doesn't really defend G6 in any way
has my opponent like trying to take the
bishop and not not sure why it's not not
going through
gotta make a rather post
some bug with chess.com
we haven't seen on passant yet
at this level is uh very easily
forgotten
or very easily overlooked as a rule
but yeah I'm really showing no mercy
here
and it's still a question how do I like
how do I transform the powerful attack
into some kind of eventual checkmate
like if it's my move here Rook takes G7
seems like the obvious choice to take
the palm of check
but I think I'd be more inclined to take
with the bishop
because that's going to lead to some
very nasty discoveries
I could also take back the bishop and
black still in the same
boat
but um yeah I'm trying to show no mercy
so I'm going to take the bishop or take
the pawn first leave the bishop hanging
and now it gets a little bit
messy like a lot of things are happening
here
like both these pawns are hanging
but what's most important is the safety
of the black king
and now I'm gonna take the knights
tracking the king attacking the queen
black has only two legal moves
like there's no other way to get out of
check
I'm a little bit disappointed my
opponent resigned because there is a
cool way to finish off the game
if King Fates I'll show it here
uh White has forced checkmates in three
moves as we see from the eval bar
I was not going to take the queen
I was gonna sacrifice The Rook Rook G8
this is a very common mating idea
and after King takes Queen G1 three
months of comfort chess
thank you claglius
and now yeah wherever the King goes
Queen G7 will be checkmate
so um
anyway nice start to
uh the speed run content let's go again
playing G Chris 95.
playing Black
opponent from the country of Italy
let's play E5
oh Vienna Vienna game are we gonna see
Vienna Gambit
sometimes yeah at this level like
openings can be very unpredictable and
sporadic
uh we see a three nights
I'll make of the Four Knights this is uh
another opening I played
very early on in my chess career
still play a lot today
and yeah there's a few moves from the
white side D4 this is called the
fortnite scotch
I guess yeah I chose the name here
against us opening
there's really no other good move for
black other than to take the pawn
maybe bishop B4 was possible but uh yeah
this is the most most standard way of
playing
um and now Bishop E4 is a nice move
so
I'm developing the bishop preparing to
Castle
I also pin the knights so in many cases
I do want to win the pawn
either by taking it right away
or by taking the Knight first and then
taking the pawn
so a beginner mistake would be something
like A3 allowing takes and then takes
but Bishop C4
I think is also a mistake I think I can
just grab the pawn right away
and I think it's more useful
[Music]
to grab the pawn
while keeping the PIN
because that way yeah that way I have a
choice what to take back with
but White's treating this as a Gambit so
I have to be a little bit careful here
that I don't run into e-file travel or
trouble with F7
um I won a pawn now I just wanna
simplify get my king save
not make things too messy
now I do have to be aware that white
wants to take now because the knight's
no longer pinned
and if I take twice on C3 the probably
gives white enough time to
annoy me
if we imagine Bishop takes takes takes
there's Queen E1 hitting my king and
knights
so I think what I'll do I'm gonna take
with the bishop
I like mine in the center
and now
yeah I'm debating between castling or
playing D5
again taking the pawn I think is just a
a big mistake so
let's prioritize King safety
and let's see if white can stir up some
compensation
a question about Bishop takes F7
yeah after the game I can definitely try
and uh address that
um
maybe it was possible
although in in most cases like if I just
go back
like here Bishop takes S7 King takes
Queen F3 hits the knight in King but I
would have Knight of six
okay so we're getting a position where
um
everything's going well I I castled my
king I won the pawn reinforced the
knights
now the knights attacked place
so let's defend it and this is a case
where the Rook is on the open file
okay opponents
attacking the knights
I really want to exploit the fact that
the the Rooks align with the queen but
like if that moves forward anywhere the
queen just takes it
so I think I'm better off just
retreating
yeah this is an educational speed run
but as I explained in the beginning
um I'm I have to play about 15 games to
get a lesser volatile rating so this is
basically a a pre-show to the actual
speed run
and the theme will be like educational
but also no mercy
it'll be showing how to punish amateur
mistakes
hopefully show the the Journey of
beginner to master
okay opponent wants to probably do this
in Checkmate me
so
A good rule of thumb like when you're on
material
try and trade
offering Queen drain
I'm not actually sure what I'll title
the speed run or whatever video series
comes of this
or YouTube like it
maybe speedrun is uh not the most
accurate name
maybe raiding climb
okay this is actually turning into uh
an interesting moment
because this Pawn is attacked and hard
to defend like even if I try and defend
it
Queen and Bishop form a battery
I was looking at let's move briefly to
hit the the queen and Bishop but that
would allow Queen H4 and then like H7
becomes a Target
in some variations
so I think I'm better off just like
caching or basically cashing in and
consuming another pond
maybe it looks a little bit greedy but
if white takes here it's just a trade
I'll still be up upon
but yeah I still have to be careful
and in this position it's a matter of
basically figuring out how to complete
development because my bishop and Rook
are
not so well in the game
I think I'll play the move C5
because the pawns on light squares don't
combine well with the the bishop so
like later on the bishop will be less
obstructed
but C5 also with friends to play C4 and
essentially trap this bishop on D3
like if I get in this move then all the
squares are are covered
recovers E2 and Bishop covers F5
so Bishop B5
but now I don't mind to trade Bishop D7
if takes I take with knights
white could get some initiative
and this initiative is a term I use a
lot
um basically refers to the side that's
making continual threats
or the one dictating play
so rookie one
challenging the open file
if take take
I think maybe a lot of players would be
inclined to trade here but taking as I
think a mistake because it just gives
white the fully open file I can't easily
challenge it
so the question becomes what to do
I just take another Pawn
when life gives you free food
you eat it
threatening to win another Free Pawn
yeah I'm completely okay with the
staring contest too
because if white takes I take and then I
control the file
so you see Bishop E5 white wants to
check Maybe
this is the first time on this account
that someone
is threatening to win the game in one
move
but I'm not gonna allow it I'm going to
take the bishop happy to trade some more
and I could take again
[Music]
if I take again the queen centralizes
but I think I'll do that because after
the queen takes
I can take this Pawn
defending
D5 from a distance
now we're approaching a really important
point
where if white plays
what I think my opponent's gonna play
maybe not I was gonna say if white plays
this move then I would have to be
very very careful of the back rink
but for now
yeah for now let's just push my my a
pawn I want to make another queen
if I plays this and I'll deal with it
yeah again for those just joining this
is uh
this is a Genesis of what will turn into
a speed run but just getting some games
on on this account
I'll probably put like the series of
these games on on YouTube as a
standalone video
okay my opponent perhaps saw that I was
attacking this Pawn but I was also
attacking The Rook
so no mercy
let's come back
are we gonna see H6
thanks for the read
Camry and Heidi
I appreciate that
yeah if you're just joining I'm playing
chess
I'm on a new account called oh no my
Rosen
let's keep pushing
okay my opponent again is threatening to
win in one move so
uh the I think the simple approach here
is to to play this
if I were to play G6 then Queen E5 would
actually maybe be a little bit annoying
okay now we push
a point resigns
okay so this message says play one more
game to be rated because account is so
new I guess you need
a certain number of games for the
reading to display
um I can address the question from
earlier about Bishop takes off seven
I think maybe a few people were asking
about this
it does look a little bit scary that the
queen can check and my king seems open
[Music]
but in general like if Queen H5
than King f8 I think is a safe Square
and there's all these cases where the
queen attacks the king and Knight but I
just go back and defend
and if Queen F3
I'll share this because this is useful
to keep in mind as well I could again
plain I have six or I could play Queen
F6
and say oh no my knight and then pin the
queen and the king so
a couple ways to
be completely okay and maybe continue to
trap white and win more material
if I win all five games is it going to
give me a 2500 rating
only one way to find out right
playing double ace
what's my rating currently
still provisional okay A10
not jumping up that high
so yeah let's play another King's Pawn
opening
I'm not gonna play Stafford yeah but oh
okay
oh we have the famous uh Wayward Queen
attack
so
um my opponent is hoping that I play G6
and blunder Queen takes E5 which will
win the Rook
uh the best way to meet this opening is
simply to defend against White's threat
white is wanting to take the pawn
I develop and defend
now White's gonna play this move
and white wants to track meet me
a lot of people
[Music]
don't realize this they play like this
or this and like they got mated
myself included actually my very first
tournament it was round three
I had this position I forget if I played
Knight F6 or Bishop C5
but I lost in four moves and I was on
the verge of crying
but since then I've learned my lesson
and G6 is now a fine move because white
can't safely take
so Queen F3 attacking my my F Pawn once
again
um so the key to dealing with this
opening is just identify the threat and
stop the threat in the best way possible
and um I want to follow opening
principles so I'll just keep developing
my Knights towards the center
um I should note the queen defends the
Knight so
I'm safe for the time being
and now I'm just gonna focus on getting
castled
it's clear that white wants to do this
and
yeah I'm happy to just castle and make
sure things are super super solid
my first tournament one was when I was
eight years old
and I went into the tournament not
knowing Scholars mates
it is fascinating like how aggressively
my opponent is playing here
I imagine this works like a decent
amount at this like rating level
but not against me I'm gonna punish this
to the full extent
D5 not only hitting the bishop in the
pawn but
unleashing my abyssip to attack the
queen
and what's important to note here is
Queen H7 is not checkmates
because of Knight defense
I remember when I was first starting
chess
like seeing this night move
was like very eye-opening
because I had games where players would
take your thinking it's Checkmate but
it's not checkmates
and this game brings back so much
nostalgia
there goes White's Queen
yeah and this at this rating level like
when D5 is played
it's so easy to tunnel vision and like
focus in the center
and not realize that the queen was
attacked
so it's so important like even if you're
if you're getting attacked you have to
really see the whole board
and address all of the opponent's
threats
and also when you're when you're The
Winning Side just keep looking for free
things
um this has been a big theme so far like
if if the point gives you a free gift
you take it
and you give nothing in return
that's really just the key to becoming
like 1000 ELO
just take everything that's free and
yeah don't
don't return the gifts
so this is rabbit chess although that
felt like a blitz and or bullet game
maybe towards the end
so gaining some rating
I think I've played let's see how many
games on this account
I've played five games total on this
account three of the Stream
so my goal is to play maybe 10 more
let's see how much energy I have but
we'll keep going
hopefully that was a good lesson how to
deal with Scholars mates
and
yeah I'm gonna stick with kind of the
the traditional opening repertoire
sticking with what I used to play when I
was rated below a thousand
just standard King's Pawn I think this
teaches you a lot about like basic
opening principles and strategies
um Bishop B5 this is a Spanish there's a
lot of ways
to meet this opening I'm going to play
the most common move just Asics
and we see Bishop A4 so this is
this is a line that uh I mean we're
still following like World Championship
level play
like nepo ending had this position a
bunch
Magnus has had this position
[Music]
okay I'll keep playing the theory so
there's a lot of ways to develop here
um Bishop E7 is is one way
at a lower level generally I recommend
to bring the bishop to the more active
Square
but I I couldn't resist just being
curious how how much Theory my opponent
would play
Knight C3 is not
not a super common Movement Like a GM
level but it's it's very natural just
developing towards the center
and um also reinforcing the pawn
so this is probably where
I just want to defend I'm gonna play D6
defend the pawn
I do kind of walk into a pin but I'm
writing to Castle knocks move
and I was about to say I didn't want to
bring it up but after this move Pawn D4
there is a potential trap that my
opponent can walk into
and that trap starts with B5
and the trap is called the Noah's Arc
trap
presumably because it's like so old
it's probably been around for hundreds
of years
there's different ways to get it but
Noah's Ark trap is like most common in
Spanish or Roy Lopez opening
and it happens in this specific
configuration where I've already
expanded with A6 and B5 and white has
played this D4 break
and basically what I can do here is
trade on D4
and at first this looks like a fair
trade like White's gonna take I'm going
to take and White's gonna take
and so far it's uh it's all been a fair
trade but after the next move
Pawn C5 this is kind of the the
underlying idea of the Trap is the
Queen's attacked and I'm threatening to
trap the bishop
and White's actually just losing a piece
here
so this is not something you'll see at
like the low rating level too often
but I guess it's a nice trick to
basically just win material against
players around this rating
it's hard to blame my opponent like they
played very natural moves
but probably what white needed to do
like after B5 white should have thrown
in the counter attack
okay so they realize that uh yeah the
bishop is a goner
they take away my castling rights
but I don't mind uh having the king here
it's nice having that extra Bishop
it's hard for white to actually exploit
the king
and assuming the queen moves to
somewhere somewhere safe
um my next couple moves will be a very
typical
sequence whenever
whenever the king finds itself on F7
there's a term called artificial
castling or casting by hand
where even though I can't legally Castle
I'm gonna basically set up the casting
formation with rook f8 and king G8
Knight D5 opponent wants opponent is
maybe hoping
that I'll take and then they can take
and hit my king and my Rook
I'm actually gonna go for this
I'll give my opponent an ounce of Hope
because after this move I have Bishop E6
defending
my king and defending the Rook
I'm happy to trade so why not
question why not Rook e8s that's a very
fair question rookie it was also
possible
e-file is half open
I like The Rook on f8 because file is
also open and there's cases maybe later
it can exert pressure against white
setup
I was not expecting my opponent to
pre-move Queen takes AIDS
that would have been funny though like
maybe I should have
bothered a little bit longer before
playing visual E6
okay so my point wants to develop the
bishop formulate some attack
but I will
get the diagonal first
attacking the rook and preventing Bishop
B2
and yeah hopefully we'll see here how to
[Music]
convert the material advantage into
eventually checkmates
um it's always nice being up material
there are a couple strategies like when
you're up material
the default strategy for a lot of
players is to trade
but the other strategy is just to
organize an attack like if you have more
pieces to attack with
then the opponent might be short on
defense
so the goal now is to play Queen F6 and
have
maybe three maybe eventually four
attackers if I triple up on that file
against F Pawn
Bishop G5 okay hitting the queen
debating what to do
I could offer the trade
but I'm gonna play yeah let's let's go
for uh
attacking ideas still
the queen seems a little bit out of play
on The Queen side but the idea is to
play C4
which would
basically create the battery of the
queen and Bishop
and I still have the idea of doubling up
either with Rook A7 to F7
or Rook F7 and then Rook f8
that's another thing like in my early
days of Chess I remember like being
impressed that you can double up in
multiple ways like it always seems more
natural to play Rook F7 and then put the
other Rook behind but
the way of going in front is also very
fine
and sometimes when you're choosing like
where to put your Rooks
it can be a decision because there's
cases where like you want your Rooks on
the two
half open files or open files
um but then there's other cases where
you want them doubled on a single file
so because f-pawn seems to be the main
focal point
which my employment clearly abandoning
here
I'm more focused on that file
so
I think they they just didn't realize
that there was going to be some issue
here
and not only do I win the pawn but yeah
it's double attack
no mercy
I think we're going to see King H1
oh King F1
it's a very brave move putting the Rook
or putting the King on the same file as
my Rook
and this is a spot where every single
bishop move will be check
the nature of discover check
I'm trying to calculate like if there's
any
any winds here any like forcing mates
I'd love to play Bishop C4 but then Pawn
takes Bishop
so I think I'm best off like cashing in
a lot of players maybe would take the
Rook right away I was looking for
something stronger but
yeah I think simple is best
and now I'm gonna play C4
the idea of unleashing the queen like
the queen still wants to join the party
yeah so I hope this is like instructive
so far I hope people are learning
something I know this is maybe catering
to a lower level than I
usually cater to at least on Twitch
um but assuming this goes on YouTube too
hopefully people can give feedback
um
yeah because now
I could win The Rook
but do I want to win The Rook
I I want to just check me quickly
there's a funny line like King E3 Rook
F3
I was calculating Rook F3 King D4 Queen
D2 checkmate
but it's not Checkmate because the
bishop could take
and this is why you should never resign
I'll play Rook F3 just to show
like especially at the lower levels like
there's there's Miracles that can happen
it looks like White's just toast here
but all it takes is one careless queen
move
or white to be back in the game
so
yeah where is my checkmates
like there's not any great looking
Chucks like Rook T3 is off limits
Queen F2 walks into the queen trade
so in these cases like generally it's
nice to keep tracking the king but I'll
play a move that's not a check
it's my King's very safe like White's
not getting any counter attack in the
next move
and with this move I'm threatening this
Checkmate and this Checkmate and this
checkmate three different mates in One
also hitting the rook in the pawn for
icing on top
okay
yeah it's a nice track mate a king was
dragged to the center
kudos to my opponent for playing on till
the very end
um and this is actually a a nice like
opening lesson to take away when you
play the Spanish as white uh sometimes
you have to be careful playing D4
which walks into this very deep trap
with Noah's Ark trap
basically like yeah why is this already
worse here because
uh the queen can't recapture without
allowing C5 which wins the bishop
so I'm pretty sure white should have
taken first and this would have gotten
messy like I would take take
but then at least White's not losing a
piece
also D5 he has those questions about D5
in the chat
um this is a counter attack
and if we got this position I can choose
whether to move the Knight or take the
bishop
I think both moves would be playable
um maybe I would move the Knight and
then eventually trade and
then castle and yeah the game would
continue
so
actually maybe this would be bad to go
for because yeah B5 was is hanging due
to the PIN
so who knows what would have happened
so uh that's seven games total right
oh no that's six games total
oh man so this this could be a longer
YouTube video if this goes on YouTube
maybe I'll trim it up a little bit
a new game
and again my rating is provisional so
I'm I'm raising reading at a pretty high
rate
and we have a king spawn Okay so
again I'm not really going for any
specific opening repertoire
I do get questions like all the time
what's the best beginner opening and
generally I recommend E4 because it's it
leads to the most like fluid opening
developments
uh my opponent plays a move which
doesn't defend the pawn
and actually going back to this position
just to explain there's a lot of moves
black can play
to defend the pawn
I think the general rule is if black
doesn't defend the pawn you just take it
like there's no move back can play
to set up a trap where the pawn is
poisonous
this is actually a very important Pawn
the black should usually hold on to
oh but black just wants to Checkmate me
okay
so this I don't mind so much
um
because we'll we'll deal with it
now it's important to address the two
threats that black has obviously Queen
F2 is one of them ambition F2
but black is also threatening to take
here
so if I play a move like G3 Queen takes
E4 hits my king my knight and my Rook
so I'm gonna play a move which defends
everything Queen F3
and there there is a principle in chess
uh usually in like in the opening that
you should not
usually develop your queen early but
there are exceptions to that rule
and here
um we're gonna see
see me use the queens of the full
potential
no mercy checkmate
so lock all the tastes of your own
medicine there
were trying to Checkmate me on F2
I defended but also attacked the point
did not realize the threats
suffered the consequence
so yeah going back
um
this is generally why Knight C6 is just
a better move hold on to the pawn
but hopefully the service is a good
lesson like identify the threats find
the move to defend everything
um black should have played this move
to obstruct my queen
and then the game would have gone on
maybe here I attack the queen
uh although wait if I attack the queen I
lose the pawn so
um I should follow the same process
identify the threats and then just
defend probably Knight C3 is one of the
best moves
okay moving on
yeah a lot of the beginner lessons to
take away
a lot of beginner mistakes that were
punishing so far
and yeah when it comes to openings
against E4 I think E5 is like one of the
best speaker openings to start with
just very classical chess opponent's
playing D4 which
is a more confrontational move this is
called the the center game
um now C3 would have led to gambits like
Danish or Goring
um but with the queen taking
I can develop and attack the queen
and yeah going back to the principle of
why you usually shouldn't bring out your
queen early
is
usually lose time because if the queen
gets attacked you have to keep moving
the queen and that slows down
development of the other pieces
so here I can't usually attack the queen
so I'll just uh develop a knight
and we see even though I'm black I move
seconds
I have two nights developed white only
has a queen developed
but it's not so easy to actually like
punish white so much
and that's the question what to do I
want to play Bishop C5 like the standard
square but that just loses a bishop
uh this move looks passive
Bishop B4 check is an option which I
might actually play
I think I I will play Bishop E4
and a lot of beginner games I I see this
early check
and most of the time it's not great if
the point can just play C3 and force the
bishop to move again
but in this specific case if white plays
if white were to play C3 my plan was
going to be Bishop A5 to B6 to then
chase the queen away from the square
um so that's one of those cases where it
probably would have been Justified
to give the check
but with Knight C3 okay the knight's
pinned which I'm happy about
the move I really want to play here is
D5
exploit the pinned Knight but if white
takes it's a check
so I'm in the castle
it's casting quickly
and yeah this whole setup
is basically asking to get punished with
D5
but I can't play it yeah it's if I play
D5 I lose the bishop so
let's maintain the PIN
taking was maybe a possibility but I
really like just keeping the bishop on
the board
and now there's cases yeah where the
bishop can find a new home
which it does
now forcing the White Queen to move
again so
already this game the Queen's move twice
has to move a third time
there's a question why I wasn't afraid
of E5 before castling
I can show that later I think there
would have been some nice ideas if
white wine for E5
but uh yeah let me focus on the position
at hand we see Queen D3
so
I still want to play D5 but now the
queen pawn and knights are controlling
the square
so there's three attackers and there's
only two Defenders
so I'm gonna play Rook E8 first
essentially pinning one of the things
that was controlling D5
and rookie it's just a happy move you
see this a ton when when you're the
first one to Castle opponent's king is
still in the center you want your Rook
aligned with opponent's king
and now D5
so even though it looks like there's
still three attackers only two Defenders
this Pawn doesn't actually count
um but we don't see the capture we see
the push
and again it's a counting game
um I have two attackers there's only one
Defender so
I could win the pawn I could also leave
the pawn here because it's pinned but
let's be simple let's win the pawn
yeah in a lot of these situations I'm
trying to play like simple easy to
understand chess
not overthinking things
um
yeah opponent did not give me time to
take the queen
so
I assume that's why they resigned
generally you shouldn't resign on your
opponent's turn like even if you make a
obvious mistake you just wanna
like
see if they actually find the move that
you overlooked but
I was I was probably gonna find Knight
takes Queen
so going back I'll address a few
questions from chats
yeah if E5 maybe there were a few
moments that
white could have gone for this move
if E5 here I can play Knight G4
and this hits the queen and
the pawn
and um
yeah this is an opening I've I've
studied before like I know that Knight
G4 is like the best move for black
but also just from a logical point of
view it's uh
yeah it should be should be clear why
black is happy here
so
yeah then white didn't have time to play
E5
although I will say like for an example
if white plays C3 and then let's say
Bishop A5 and 95
this would be interesting because I
don't have Knight G4
I think most people would play Knight D5
which looks completely fine
um the move I would probably play here
is not moving the Knight
and just castling
and this is where I can say oh no my
knight
and then play rookie a and win the queen
so it's this is a very common like
opening tactical theme when especially
when the Queen and King are aligned on
an open vial
there can be repercussions
okay let's move on
hey I broke a thousand ELO I have a more
established rating
but again I have to play um
a handful more games to get uh
something less provisional so we see B3
usually with like the non-standard moves
against openings that are not E4 or D4
we just want to control the center
everyone's doing weird stuff
we'll just have two Pawns in the center
um and develop no need to overthink
things
I don't know what possessed my opponents
maybe they watch my video winning with
the crowd opening
but this is like some weird
combination of like a crab and a hippo
and this is probably where we can start
punishing the opponent for
breaking too many opening principles
like not playing in the center not
developing Knights and Bishops moving
the same piece twice
okay so I my plan was actually to go for
a quick attack against F2 like I wanted
to play Knights G4 and queen F6
with this move E3
it's important to understand the bishop
no longer has great scope
but the light Square especially the
square F3 is no longer
controllable by a white Pawn because
these pawns have both committed
um
so this is maybe a bit higher level of a
strategic concept but this F3 square is
like permanently weak because my Pawn
controls F3
so I'm going to try and make full use of
that with this move Knight E5
oh okay and now now we get to see on the
sun opponent probably is Overjoyed that
they got to Fork me
but uh on the song
if you haven't seen this move before you
can Google it
you can also hover over here and
yeah chess.com explains
this is one feature on chess.com that uh
I don't think exists on Lee chess a
little info icon
okay
so now white wants to play D4 again and
then I can't on the sun and that would
be a fork
although it's probably not so lethal
because D4 Bishop B4 I'm not losing a
piece
but what do I want to do
I could play D4 myself but that allows
E4 not sure how much I'm getting there
okay I'm gonna play Bishop G4 I think
this is the most sensible move
attacking the queen
developing my final minor piece
and now
yeah now there's a cool idea to play
visual B4 check
I'm playing this move based on like a
two move tactical combination that we're
gonna see play out
um but this move was also like logical
from a strategic standpoint because
Bishops don't like staring at Pawn
chains so Bishop's just happier along
with the King
um so now uh I can win a pawn
and it looks confusing because yeah
Bishops the Bishops are having some
staring contests
but there's a pawn that's not defended
in White's position
is this Pawn on D3
the bishop doesn't actually defend it
because it's pinned to the queen
so finally winning material after
such an opening
I mean white only has two legal moves
here
King F1 definitely the best move
I do have to be careful because White's
threatening to take a lot of different
things now
and the approach is probably going to be
to trade off
I imagine starting with Bishop takes E2
is like the most forcing move
thank you no mercy I like your name
appreciate the raid
yeah if you're just joining this is
chess
um I'm playing on a a brand new account
this is a preliminary speedrun
kind of speed running
my rating to a more established rating
so this game I'm I'm only up a pawn
and actually I have to be a little bit
careful because my Bishop has gone a
little bit deep into White's territory
but I'm realizing
it's not that simple to save the bishop
wow
you know it's crazy
yeah because if I move here here so
first of all if I move here
there's Queen B5
I lose the bishop if I move here
Queen B5 I guess sees six defends but
then Queen takes B7
um
this is where I might have to pull some
tricks from my
my high level chess abilities
appreciate all the content and teaching
oh I I appreciate you thank you Paradise
AF
yeah I'm gonna play a move here of that
I don't think anyone rated 1028 ELO
would find
I don't even know if it's a good move
but it's based off some
very deep
tactical idea
maybe not super deep but it's a very
aesthetic tackle tactical idea
involves sacrificing the bishop
at first this move looks
like kind of useless because I'm just
allowing white to threaten the trade
but the idea is now I have Queen F6
threatening mate and threatening to take
the Rook with Chuck
so when I played Knight E4 I I saw this
coming and
um whites and a pretty big predicament
now
very big predicament
okay so that kind of ended up roughly
uh I was very close to being worse there
after trying to punish like
was a terrible terrible opening it's
actually kind of crazy
I was maybe a little bit
complacent when deciding what to capture
like maybe I should have captured
[Music]
although I don't know maybe I should
capture the bishop first
yeah I also want to show like
I addressed if here than white wins a
bishop
and if I were to play Bishop A5
I address it like when the pawn like
here here
I saved my king and my Bishop
lose a pawn but I think there's a
stronger move here Pawn B4
because again if I take I lose the
bishop and if I hear the bishop gets
trapped
so like if I was playing a strong player
and played Bishop A5 I think like
White's much much better
but this Knight E4 move it's possible
White's still like better here somehow
like maybe white could have played
Knight F3
oh but then they still have yeah Queen
F6 was such a key resource
um
I've avoided using the engine for
analysis of these games but I'm just
curious like what does engine have to
say
White's better after Knight T2
so if my opponent doesn't hang
checkmates
White's objectively better if they take
the Knight I was going to take the Rook
with check
and then after takes takes even though I
have
a rook for Knights
white has a media attack and is winning
the pawn
and whatever I do with my king
then these things are attacked because
he played spell chess for the first time
and I helped her get used to it she
loves the variant nice she needs to
learn duck chess though
yeah there's always more to learn anyway
this would have been crazy if uh
yeah if I got a worse position from here
um
but good games my opponents uh clearly
yeah just fight the troll opening
uh White found some like reasonable
moves to
to almost be better
so moving on
playing dilip chess
I imagine for like the official speedrun
I'll probably mix up the openings a bit
more
but for now
yeah we're gonna just follow basic
principles
trying to show that you don't need to
know like so much deep opening Theory at
this level
um and this is a modern opening
this is usually a system that
black will basically play these moves
and
uh
not react to what I'm doing like my
opponent's just following a basic setup
I'm also kind of doing my own thing
I got two Pawns in the center got my
minor pieces developed
and yeah very much ready to Castle
except that my opponent just walked into
a cool tactical trap
and I'm gonna show no mercy and take on
F7
this is a very common idea when the
opponent pins the night early
and this Bishop's not defended
we're gonna see how this plays out
Knight G5
and wherever the king moves I'm gonna
win back the bishop
won the pawn in the process your
opponent must be thinking oh no Morrison
what's a rosin what's a rosin yeah
sometimes I think the same thing
yeah I really need to figure out what my
profile picture will be
for this account
but I prefer for other people to decide
for me so
um yeah probably when whenever this goes
on YouTube then I'll have some comments
to read
all right so now I take the bishop
now this tactic would not have worked if
black had already developed a knight to
F6
and this is what black should have done
like Knight F6 and then later Bishop G4
is a more acceptable way of playing the
opening
so I was gonna say like maybe we would
see Bishop takes D4 but then I would
have Knight E6 with just a monster
position
although
okay so I could still play Knight E6
but that would walk into Bishop takes D4
and I can't take back because my knight
would be pinned to the queen
so this is another case where I'm up
upon
trading Queens is completely fine
but there is this
general rule in chess which probably
overrides
the rule of when you're on material you
should simplify
and the rule is
if you're offered a queen trade you
should identify which king is more
vulnerable
and because Black's King is more
vulnerable because it's lost casting
rights
uh White should keep Queens on the board
so no Queen trade
I'm keeping my queen
uh setting up now Queen F7 yeah we see
this theme so much like so many games
that opponents are
not realizing the the weakness of this
outside and square
now Queen f8 does not Checkmate because
Queen E8
but uh this looks pretty strong 96
working the king and the bishop
I think a lot of people would just take
the bishop but sometimes when you see a
good move
you should try and seek out the best
move
and the best move is Queen f8 here
and this is trackmates uh next move
black has two legal moves and I'll take
with Meats
good job Toulouse who saw it coming
realizing I'm like almost out of t
this is my maple walnuts
Essentia green tea
but still have a few more games to play
yeah if you see Maiden one look for
better
if you see made in one look for
onpassant mates or Castle mates
okay so this is a situation
um
my appointment might be like searching
for miracle resource
I was gonna say maybe maybe they were
trying to use their jump spell
like jump over the Knight to take the
queen but this doesn't spell chess
I know there's some players that will
rage quit or
let their time run
longer but uh okay yeah I've only played
it quickly enough
so that was nice kind of opening trap
lesson again I'm not really intending to
play tricky openings but if opening
traps come up and while I'm playing then
I'm I'm not gonna hold back
and one point to make is when you
develop your pieces harmoniously and
follow principles very often that will
lead to tactics like when your pieces
are in good squares that will allow you
to uh punish the Pawn's mistakes
more swiftly
so
moving on
playing or fan
from the country of Bangladesh
okay
um yeah again playing
traditional openings
so we've seen we've seen a few different
openings so far
um we saw Vienna or like four nights
earlier we saw the Wayward Queen but now
we have something traditional
um I'm just realizing my dog wants to be
let out so I'm going to be right back
and uh when I get back I'm gonna explain
this opening in more depth BRB
okay
so much suspense
so um I gave away a piece for a pawn but
the reason for it
is I got the fork
this is called the center for trick
I'm a little bit out of breath I ran
down and up the stairs
but um
okay so we basically traded
pawns and minor pieces
but black has a a small Advantage
because okay first of all I have the
bishop pair
and I have a more advanced Pawn
on E5
and I'm gonna just pin
on my earbud
and this is one of the like very first
I don't think I would call it an opening
trap but one of the first openings I
learned
as a young player
um and you hear
how aggressive do I want to be
like generally you should Castle before
you start attacking but I think here
it's completely fine fine to
just attack right away
94 the knights pinned and now attack
twice
I'm threatening to take and just destroy
White's Pawn structure
on the king side
and yeah this is what we're gonna see
now I could actually decide
um between taking with a bishop or the
knights but
I like the idea of taking the Knight and
then getting in Bishop H3 after Pawn
takes
and yeah after the game I'll I'll
address some more specific questions
about the center for trick
because there were other options for
lights but generally black is is happy
with whatever outcome
okay so this is a case where
I don't actually have like a strong
attack it's more a long-term
long-term Pleasant position because
White's pawns are
are very much fractured
but it's hard to actually get my queen
to
G2 and even if I maneuver
somehow to G6 I was going to be Knight
G3 to defend
so here I think I'm better off just
completing developments
I could Castle queenside
I could play F5 is interesting
I would like to be like as flexible as
possible I'm just gonna play Bishop E7
and then depending what white does and
I'll decide whether I want the castle
kingside or queen side maybe later go
for F5
and here okay so F4 actually looks like
a very logical move at first
because white wants to remove this pawn
and maybe
use the x-ray vision of The Rook align
with my king
uh the drawback of this move is it opens
up this diagonal actually like creates a
pin
the Knight is now pinned to the chat
mating Square
but can I exploit it because if I play
F5
which honestly like I
right after F4 I thought F5 was just
winning the knights it's not that simple
obviously if the Knight moves I wouldn't
checkmates but F5 there's Queen H5
one big lesson to take away here is
every move
can change multiple things in the
position
like F4 attacks this but opens this
F5 attacks this but opens my king to
annoying checks
so
I want to be a little bit more
thoughtful
and this is a case where I'm considering
a few different like candidate moves
considering taking
concerning F5 which probably trades but
I don't think I want to allow
lights easily win the bishop
considering some crazy like G5 open the
G file
I mean I still have options of castling
I have to watch out for my time too I've
earned a lot of time uh letting the dog
out
it's actually a fascinating move at four
here's what I'm going to do I'm in the
castle
I think my king is safest on the queen
side even though okay I guess white
could maybe take the pawn but my king
will still be safe
oh
good move
I was gonna say that I was threatening
at five then with my king no longer on
E8
but life finds a very good resource
and yeah again I don't really want to
lose my Bishop
so let's move back
yeah I really thought I'd be getting
more of an advantage but um
yeah things didn't quite go my way
but sometimes in life this will happen
if I have another fine move
oh dear F5
I'm realizing if I play Bishop no Bishop
D7 is fine
for a brief moment I thought Knight D6
wins a queen
um it does attack my king and queen but
Knight T6 I just take it
but yeah obviously this is not what I
was hoping for like whites White's
basically thrown punches for the last
what starting with F4 Queen F3 like
every move white is like punching me
in the face kind of
where does my queen go
I could take the pawn
if I take the pawn
and the queen looks very precarious but
I don't see anything wrong
with stagging the pawn because then this
Pawn will be hanging
I should know the move like Knight C5
attack my queen and threatening mates
allows me to take the knights
and this move so this move is the first
move whites played in a while
that isn't punching me in the face
and the concept is basically white has
no longer
or has basically like stopped making
threats
it's a purely defensive move
and now it's my turn to start throwing
punches
Bishop C6
pinning and attacking the knights
now no mercy we'll just take a free
night
Rook supported on D.A Queen supported on
an E4
found some good moves there though
I coped with the opening trebles pretty
well
yeah sometimes players will play Above
their rating
um but my opponent also made some
like lower level mistakes this game
uh maybe starting with like the opening
play
I'm curious if maybe White had something
else other than B3
okay so now it's a matter of actually
like moving quickly to
um
to not lose on time
I know a lot of players maybe in the
like sub 1500 range they'll freak out
when they get low on time
especially if they're used to playing
longer chess
and what's most important is to
just make gradual improvements
and usually look for simplifications
especially because we're in the end game
it's not realistic I'm gonna be creating
a mating that anytime soon
but I'm happy with trades Pawn trades
are fine
a bishop trade would be nice
oil avoids the train this is a good
strategy when you're when you're behind
you don't want to um simplify too much
okay and take take a free Pawn why not
so in addition like when you're when
you're had in the game and you're you're
entering an end game you want to
simplify you want to take three things
if the opponent gives it
but then another very important
principle that will allow you to win
more quickly
is identify your past pawns and push
your past Pawns
in this position okay Rick's attack
let's not lose it
this position I have three pass Pawns
a pass Pawn is defined by
basically it's a pawn that can't be
stopped by an opponent Pawn
so because
white has three pawns here none of these
pawns are passed because they're these
just get in the way
but light has no pawns to stop uh stop
these guys oops I just hung up a rook
okay
oh dear and I have low time
maybe I am playing at like 1100 ELO
okay so now now we're gonna see a
different lesson this is how to fight
back from a bad situation
hopefully I won't embarrass myself
further
uh thankfully like objectively the
position should still be winning for
black
but I made my life a lot more difficult
because I no longer have a rook
but I'm gonna follow the same strategy
just push the Pawns
I should have remembered the
one of the the earlier principles don't
give anything away for free
how did I allow that
yeah I I was so focused on
being happy with my past Pawn
okay let's keep pushing
I'm doing some high level calculations
here H3
Rook takes H2 is almost winning but then
Chuck here and then here I think you
must
oh yeah
oh it's a zoo
okay let's uh
Let's Play Bishop F5
want to make sure the bishop still
contributes
so white has a move here it's a
threatened Checkmate in one white can
play this threatening Rook d a checkmate
but then I'll have a nice response
oh white does it
that would be a big mistake to push the
past Pond allowing Rook T8
but here I can play Bishop H3
and sometimes the best defense is attack
white has no time to play this the
king's in Chuck
the king's also stuck in this small
quadrant
and it's it's made in two more moves
King G1 F2
and the queen is is coming
so that was a close one
I'm glad I blundered the rook and not
checkmates
but it's another lesson like
and actually it happens across all
levels from beginner to master
is sometimes when you're in a winning
position it's just much much easier to
be careless and make mistakes
so when you are in the winning position
usually you just want to stay focused
and still be aware of what the opponent
is threatening
on the flip side when you're in a losing
position
you don't want to give up
you want to fight for every opportunity
except when you're in this position as
white you can resign or just make your
only legal move
okay
oh I can under promote
um
that would be tragic if I Mouse slipped
under promoting tonight and a loud
checkmate
not happening though
thank you salvi games
okay I don't want to spend too much time
analyzing this but there was a question
earlier
um what about Bishop takes F7
which it's a scary looking move
the idea is White's losing a piece
anyway after D5
why not just give the bishop take away
black Black's castling rights
um when I was younger I thought like
this looks really good for whites I
actually argued with my first chess
coach that man this has to be good for
white look at the Knights coming in this
king is exposed it's equal material
but the truth about this position is
black is much much better after D5
Knight G5 is only one check
whichever Knight comes to G5 just King
G8
and the knight's gonna get kicked this
Knight sometimes gets kicked it's not
good for whites
um and if Knight G3
then
[Music]
I think E4 is the best move because this
Knight has nowhere good to go
I only see a square is back to G1
and then black can kind of do the same
technique of artificial castling
I assume like Bishop maybe bishop C5
here
because Queen H5 there's G6 and box plan
is this and this and then Target the the
pawn and have a nice Center
so
I hope that answers the question
yeah sometimes this will happen in the
opening where the opponent will like
sacrifice a piece or do a fancy trade
and then you just essentially castle by
hand
of course you want to have a sense of
danger with your king here but generally
it's it's fine
so
um new game
okay E4
so the ratings of my opponents are
increasing
as my rating increases
and we're going to have another
a pretty standard opening
ah so here we have the Philadelphia
um the philodor it has a solid slightly
passive reputation
it does defend the pawn but at the same
time it blocks of Bishop in
usually white is happy just to get
quick development more space
I already have three minor pieces
developed
black has just pushed Pawns
yeah a sense of danger refers to just
being aware of your weaknesses in the
position like if your king is exposed
you want to be very aware of what the
point might be threatening
wow I was not even intending to like go
for an opening trap here
but I'm pretty sure there's a trap here
pretty sure I can take the pawn
because after Pawn takes I play Bishop
D5 trapping The Rook
it's a slightly unusual tactic I'm gonna
go for it
I guess I should note that black has D5
and then
things might get very messy but yeah
black just uh walks into this and even
though I gave away a night for a pawn
I'm just winning The Rook there's no way
to defend it
it's uh
it's a cool tackle pattern
like sometimes you see this in different
openings Queen's Gambit accepted being
one of them
yeah xqc would be very proud of this
wooden Shield
[Music]
in all seriousness like D5 would have
made things super messy because I think
I would be losing a piece there I
wouldn't have the same idea of trapping
the rook and my main Bishop would be
attacked
but if Black's just moving pawns so
early
um and the Center opens up I think
there'd be a lot of compensation
okay so Life Goes On
important to note here the Bishops
attacked
but I can save it
and I'll save it by
using it's using it to its full
potential
Bishop D7
um yeah I'll just trade
of material and castle
it feels weird that like there's been
this whole mess on the queen side but it
still feels like I'm kind of in the
opening phase
black is maybe wanting to win the pawn
here I'm not gonna defend the pawn I'm
gonna just push D4
it's basically a counter attack of two
attackers against E5
and I'd love it I was gonna say I'd love
it if the the Center opens and I gotta
Rook to E1 with uh the Kingston e8s
and here I have an option I could play
rookie one first or take
a little bit conflicted
I think I'll play rookie one first
and then yeah assuming black like saves
the night then I'll I'll take on E5
yeah I was talking a little bit about
this earlier but the theme of the speed
run
um
it's it's supposed to be educational
overall
but then I guess there's different sub
themes of like punishing amateur
mistakes
uh following
like basic principles that will
hopefully allow you to like reach the
next level
[Music]
hopefully I'll show like the
kind of the
the things to do at each rating level to
to
um to beat like the next tier of
opponents
and again the games I'm playing here
they're they're just kind of preliminary
I'm just trying to get an established
rating
so then the admins can reset my rating
and um
then it won't be as volatile you can let
them take your pieces but
that's very deep
sometimes it'll take my time though
if they just saw
but I'll use my time to its full extent
okay so I I haven't explained like the
last few moves but it's been pretty
hopefully it's pretty self-explanatory
getting the pieces into play
I did a lot of the queen trade
um but my Rooks are so happy
and the move I really want to play is F3
chase away the Knight and then exploit
the king
now not only is my opponent preventing
me from playing F3
but they're threatening to take on F2
so
I'm looking for fancy options but I
think I'll play
I think I'll just play the the normal
option Bishop E3 challenge the bishop
make sure I'm not losing a pawn
offered to simplify
I was thinking about playing Bishop G5
going for some like cool mating Nets but
uh
not necessary
I think you've asked see us happy 32
ah there's a comment in chat Knight D3
was better yeah actually I'll admit I I
missed the fact that I could attack b as
well
but still making progress
up the exchange here
actually Knight D3 would have been a
really nice move
just to show Knight T3
defending attacking
um
I guess whatever my opponent makes the
move it it goes to the current position
[Music]
uh what to do thank you funky donkey
like I want to invade with the Rook but
d7's control d8's control and D6 doesn't
seem to have a purpose
foreign
[Music]
like generally in these engines you want
your books on the poem seventh rank if
you're white
so
Rook C3 is just a matter of getting to
C7
and the power of the Rook on the seventh
hopefully we'll see soon although now I
can't play either of these moves because
the knights are being annoying
I could play this move which I've been
called do
actually I could play this move which
looks even
nicer
because I'm essentially forcing the
trade I'm also setting up a trap if Rook
d8
just to show I've worked yet I would
take with check and then win The Rook
okay so now I got one Rook to the
seventh
and I could take the pawn but I'm gonna
put both Rooks on the seventh
and this is how you dominate these sort
of end games
so why the the combination of two Rooks
is better than rook and knights
now they create the battery and they're
basically Unstoppable like Rook F7 I
just take it
and there's really no stopping the
eventual Rook G7
yeah very often this will lead to some
amazing ideas
or just winning like all the Pawns
kind of like an all-you-can-eat buffet
and I can and I'm planning to continue
playing spell chess
uh not this stream but yeah probably in
the future
stay tuned
I once gave a lecture for St Louis chess
club on um on solely like the strategy
of of Rooks on the seventh
videos on YouTube Somewhere
I think it was called like pigs on the
seventh
the Rooks are kind of like pigs because
they just eat everything
[Music]
okay so here I'm not mating
um because the king is going to have a
square regardless of how I check
but I can threaten checkmates
like this
so now Rook Hade is the main threat
Rook h8 was not made immediately because
I wanted to hang The Rook
and okay I got paid off for it I was
gonna say that if if black refuses to
get mated
then the most efficient way to win is
usually by pushing each Pawn
get the pawn to
uh to the square for example let's say
like take
let's say Okay H War take
H5 let's say here here here
once upon is here it defends G7 and then
this is checkmate
so I hope that makes sense
okay another like nice game
um this is like a weird opening trap you
don't see too often
but uh
goes to show why it's nice to be taskly
alerts
early on
now it could have gotten very messy like
I'm not sure what I would have done
against this
I would have taken my time
and I'd probably end up taking with a
pawn and then after takes takes
white already has three Pawns
for having having given away
at night and this Pawn is hanging
so imagine the engine should be okay
with this
engine says box a little bit better
though
let's go back
after D5
what's the best move
ah
wow so there's only one move for white
to keep an edge
as just using the the same idea Bishop
B3 it's a hard move to consider
but the point is
we're just waiting for locks to take so
again we trap The Rook
and we just want a pawn but what if
takes
ah then they take C5 hitting F7
yeah maybe this is a bit messy but it
all works out for whites
unexpected opening complications
so uh let's do a quick overview of how
many games I've played
the first two games I played on this
account I I did not play on stream
but this stream I played three three
three I played 10 games so far
12 games overall
um I think I'm gonna end it here
I think we had a lot of like instructive
moments a lot of like beginner friendly
lessons
some nice opening traps basic principles
a lot of ways to punish beginner
mistakes
so I hope everyone watching learned a
thing or two if you have feedback or
the real speed run
um please let me know
I do plan to reset my rating
back to probably 400 although if people
have a better suggestion of the starting
point let me know
and it's going to be educational focused
but um
yeah let me know what you what you think
and
yeah I think I'll put this whole series
of games on the main Channel
so if you're watching in the future uh
stay tuned for a speed run let me know
if I should call the speed run or a
rating climb
or a slow run or I don't know
let me know
um I'll read the comments